Okay, so I will search for Python Standard
Library, and I got to this documentation page.
By the way, the link to this page is also
available in the instructor notes. I will check to make
sure that I am reading documentation for the version of
Python I downloaded, which is version 2.7. In here, I
can scroll down to web browser. You will notice that
it says here, that the web browser module provides a
high level interface to allow displaying web based documents to
users, which is really a fancy way of saying, it will
show you websites. And if I scroll down,
I can find the function, webbrowser.open, which takes in
a URL and displays that URL using the default browser. If I go back, I can also
find the module named time. Here it is, and if I click on it, I can read
its documentation. It says, this module provides various time
related functions, and we use two of those functions.
If you scroll down, you'll find time.ctime,
which gives the current time of the computer,
and time.sleep, which suspends execution for a given number of seconds.